the scream franchise will be getting a
new director and it's Christopher Landon
he's the guy that directed The Happy
death Day movies and more recently he
directed the movie Freaky I think he's a
great choice to take over this franchise
he's obviously very familiar and kind of
gets the whole scene of teen horror and
he's a good director he's very creative
and I think that makes him a good
candidate for this it'll be nice to see
some new creative blood injected into
the scream franchise as you probably
know the original four were directed by
Wes Craven and then the next two after
that were directed by Matt betinelli
open and Tyler Gillette and I think they
did a serviceable job of bringing back
screen but didn't really step the
franchise forward in any way Christopher
Landon is kind of known for
incorporating sci-fi elements into his
horror movies so maybe that's something
that he could use to his advantage in
the new scream I think there's a lot of
untapped potential for Scream movie
ideas maybe we see it tackle the concept
of crossover movies like they do a ghost
face versus Baby Face from the happy
death day franchise maybe he does a
Scream movie as a holiday movie I think
there's a lot of options out there but
whatever they end up going with we're
probably not going to be seeing this for
a long time because of the writers
strike but let me know your thoughts
what do you think of Christopher Landon
taking over scream and what would you
like to see in the next screen movie